good
morning millennials welcome back to the
morning chose happy hump day today is
wednesday and i'm very excited to be
joined by someone i've dreamt of humpty
of pumping for so long
and she's finally here you guys are
quaking i'm quaking it's paige disorbo
paige welcome to the toast oh my god
thank you so much i'm so excited like
very tasty i dressed for the set yeah no
you're looking good you're looking like
a part of the couch i was like what
would jackie love to say i know so this
has been really hard for jackie because
like this month we don't really have a
lot of guests on the show and this month
obviously thank you for subbing in for
jackie she's on her maternity leave and
it's like all the people jackie wants to
meet and she's like happy for the toast
but she's like devastated as well jackie
loves you well the audacity of her to
have a baby right now it's honestly
disgusting and it's so disrespectful to
you it really is it i really dumped her
and i was like it's just rude isn't it
crazy though that you wanted to be a mom
right now so nasty it's like i'm wearing
silk
area
i am so excited you're here first of all
i have like really fallen in love with
you i was like very late to the summer
house game okay um
and i really feel like your entry to the
show kind of expedited my my journey on
the show because i feel like you add
just such great energy to the show and
wow don't read twitter then oh do you
read like a lot of
i don't actually like in this past
season i haven't gone on twitter one
time so smart and you just like you
can't you can't is this a new haircut
yeah i love oh my god i chopped it last
week that's so like
brave and i mean that in a good way like
i wouldn't i'm so insecure like my hair
is like my
my like security okay well we filmed the
reunion on friday so you have this hair
and i was getting my i
like showed my hairstyles what i wanted
and i was like well you have to be
shorter for me to achieve that look so
he literally chopped it in my kitchen
like the morning
and he's like i'm cutting it and i was
like cut it oh my it looks so good how
was your union
you know
um reunion is like my least favorite day
of the year and i almost passed out in
the middle of it
and andy's like talking about god knows
what and my whole left arm went numb
holy [ __ ] my head started doing this
like weird like i literally thought i
was having a stroke and i was like here
i am having a stroke on that
tv
yeah they're gonna people are gonna be
like she planned that she like passed
out on purpose people are so annoying
you know there's a corner of the bravo
fandom that's like so [ __ ] toxic it's
insane it will it is a cult yes you know
and i asked hannah this because this is
like what i'm most curious about when it
comes to bravo reality shows is the
reunion yeah and i just want to know
like what that's like because andy's
always instagram storing he's like oh
it's 8 a.m and then it's 8 p.m and we're
still here what are those days like what
do you when do you eat when'd you go to
the bathroom so we woke up this this
past reunion amanda actually came over
to my apartment at 5 30.
we started hair and makeup we got to the
studio at nine
we start filming at like 10 30 11.
andy had a call at two so we broke for
lunch for an hour
and then we went until like 7 30. damn
yeah it's crazy that and you're probably
so irritable just because like of the
drama but then also because you're so
[ __ ] tired and also you're like i
don't care i know because it was eight a
year ago yeah like i don't
remember that's actually so true i
didn't think about that well i have like
a whole list of summer houses just
really quick questions that i want to
ask you and the first question comes
from me but it also comes from every
person on the planet where the [ __ ] is
alex
so alex oh he's so cute what's he at the
reunion um yes alex is at the reunion
the thing is that there were so many of
us this year yes and we are all
camera [ __ ] yes so like when things
are happening they just don't have
enough camera people to follow everyone
right so it's kind of like the main
stories get followed and he's like so
nice that he wasn't like screaming at
anyone i know and you know that actually
makes sense because the way that i
perceive it is like and that was my next
question it's just like the danielle of
it all how like this became danielle's
fight at the dinner party when loki had
nothing to do with danielle and i think
in the same way like you
you are to sierra what danielle is to
lindsey and like you didn't really stand
up and get involved so now knowing that
there's like a shortage of cameras like
it actually makes sense like she was
like looking for a moment because it
felt so odd to me i'm like this is a
fight between lindsay and sierra like
why the [ __ ] is danielle getting all
open but now now that actually makes
sense to me yeah and danielle definitely
goes very hard for lindsay and so
what um body did the two of them bury
together that they are like stuck
together like that it's so weird
probably strabby
so weird okay next question um oh i just
was watching last night sierra on watch
up inside looking stunning beautiful
perfect smart it's hard to look at her
sometimes it's really upsetting actually
and then andy like made the comment
about nurses and i thought that was
really funny and then like the nurses
turned on andy but john mayer was the
bartender like i was feeling something
my mom texted me and she was like all i
want is for john mayer and sierra to go
on a date i'm telling you like there was
vibes there was and i wanted to know if
like he texted her got her number or
anything i called her like immediately
the next day and i was like so you're
marrying john may right but no nothing
happened but like she did smile and i
was like oh my god no and like she was
just being so and the whole i felt bad
for andrea actually because like the
whole episode of watching live was not
about him it was about sierra and she
was just like wearing this outfit and
like she was glowing and it was like the
sierra show and i just felt like john
felt that energy for her
absolutely i'm telling you something
could happen something's going on i know
and he really likes younger girls like
borderline inappropriate but sierra's of
age and like i just think like it's it's
gonna happen yeah i would love to go to
that wedding um i have some logistical
questions about the summer house crew
because you guys are always admin you
guys are always throwing parties yeah
and amanda's always kicking everyone out
at like six o'clock why
so it gets to a point in the night where
like
okay we're done with the party like just
us as people
and we have like more things to talk
about we have more things to film and we
just don't need random people coming
into our house who are like friends of
friends trying to be like hey like well
i think we're like no one cares are you
yeah yeah but thank you so much and who
are those people who come to the parties
like hampton's hanger honors like who
are they so a lot of that like we will
invite our
core main friends and then we'll be like
bring whoever you want with you there is
like a list at the door that i don't
think anyone's ever looked at yeah um
so sometimes it does feel like a
free-for-all and amanda is just the best
at being like get the [ __ ] out get out
of here yeah and so they listen to her i
got a lot of questions for you about why
you never have your own room
i have the same question so it's not a
preference
it just ends up like working out that
way yeah like the first summer when it
was me and hannah i wanted to room with
hannah because i was like this is
terrifying yeah and i need someone with
me
and then it just was like okay well me
and hannah will always room together got
it and then when hannah left
i was like oh my god i'm gonna get my
own room and then sierra popped in and
was like wanna share and i was like sure
gotta go and now craig is here and i'm
like when will i ever be an adult right
because now i'm thinking like it feels
like craig and first of all like
the bullet i would take for you and
craig as a couple like
you don't know like how many of my brain
cells are devoted to your relationship
but not in a weird way at all yeah i
just have loved craig for a long time
and i love you and like i it's a couple
i never would have expected but it's
perfection like beyond perfection and i
don't want to put too much pressure on
you but like if you don't get married
like i will be severely mentally ill
from it so no pressure just like letting
you know just letting you know like what
the status quo is i'll let you know and
like i have just
we me and jackie were like watching
winterhouse like for the paige and craig
of it all yeah but it wasn't really it
was just the start like it wasn't the
real substance of your relationship and
now we're getting it and you and craig
seem to be in a great place
but on the show like there's like drama
and i just want to know what it feels
like to like have people talk about your
relationship because it doesn't really
happen to me a lot but when it does like
it's the worst thing ever it's just a we
it's like weird because you're like wait
i
i can see all the bad things you're
saying like talk about me behind my back
like a normal person i know like saying
it right to my face i know so crazy
but i will actually say since we've been
like up and down i feel like sometimes
people love us sometimes people hate us
it's only brought us closer together
that's great because i'm like oh my god
did you see on instagram that we're both
gained 15 pounds and he's like i didn't
see that but thank you paige and i'm
like wow
we must be in love we're getting fast so
[ __ ] funny like the way like
i'm just so obsessed like i just think
it's the greatest couple and i'm so
happy for you guys and i think a lot of
people were like quaking like how could
she not choose andre but like yeah craig
is like so clearly the right choice like
i just i really respect your taste yeah
because craig is the one like i'm
obsessed with craig also andrea was like
going through a whole thing in the
summer yeah and like you don't really
find that out until the end of the
summer and so
like more of the beginning of the summer
made so much more sense got it and what
andre and i had over the summer was
exactly what we both wanted like we
never talked right
and sometimes we would be like you're
hot you're hot right and then we're like
see ya
and that's what we needed yeah i feel
that 100
um so guys if you're not familiar with
paige she's an icon bravo icon she's
also a podcaster and we love podcasting
with other podcasters because it's just
so much easier like it's really hard to
podcast with someone who doesn't have a
podcast so thank you for being here
thank you you're also like doing the
most you guys are on tour now right
you're doing giggly squad live shows
yeah we've been doing live shows which
the first one i we did in philly and i
blacked out yeah because drunk or
nervous both got it and hannah was like
looking at me like sitting next to me
and she's like stop
and then i was like okay that was just
my first one we're gonna get into it and
now it is like i don't know how i never
did it before so much fun i live you
literally feel like you're on drugs when
you get off stage because like the calm
down of adrenaline is insane no and it's
actually really scary because like in
that moment you understand like how fame
is so addicting because you hear people
like screaming and clapping and it's for
you and it's like yeah
it's addicting every time i walk off
stage i look at hannah and i go i am
justin bieber
leave me alone that is so [ __ ] funny
no it's so much fun i've heard so many
good things about your show so if you
guys want to check out where are you
headed next um we are probably headed to
like dc next
and then we're going to announce our new
york city show fun yeah okay
yeah yeah i'm a giggly girly yeah um so
are you uh like a big pop culture girly
i think you are correct you're like a
big kardashian girly right i love kim
okay good because we have so much kim
content today when i sit down with
someone new like i never know how it's
gonna go i forever am a kim stan i feel
like you and craig like not to be
dramatic are like the pete and kim of
the bravo universe honestly craig would
murder you if you
what he like doesn't understand the
whole pete thing he's like i just like
don't really like vibe with the
kardashians and i'm like it's just weird
that i ever thought of marrying that's
toxic yeah that's extremely think i
don't love it can i just say he's such a
good part of the show like the way he
was like speaking to lindsay who like
really can't be spoken to especially
when she hits like a certain level in
the night um he's so calming and i'm
curious if like there's any plans for
him to become like a permanent summer
house cast member um i feel like he put
that hat on and he was just like i
am coachella
the hat was like a moment for craig he
was like i will help you on your
ayahuasca trap that's paige's influence
the hat
um no he would never be a full-time
summoner no he doesn't understand like
the surveillance part of it
he's like this is too much yeah and you
could tell austin didn't understand it
either when he said he wanted to eat
sierra from front to back
oh that's true because i guess and then
he would be filming like so much
year-round because like southern charm
it's a lot and southern charm films for
like two hours a day and they're like
i'm exhausted i'm like really
are you going to be on this season of
southern charm yeah a little bit [ __ ]
yes oh my god you're really just like on
one thousand bravo shows really
i also you don't say no to bravo of
course like if they're like you're on
this now you're like i'll be there so
much yeah we got a lot of questions for
you like with the new rebrand of real
houses in new york if that was ever
something you'd be interested in i don't
think so really well i don't want to get
married yet well no one on the show is
married so it doesn't matter like i feel
like the housewives are so much more
like we fight about you made out with
him yeah like you said that they say
horrible things yeah
they are like life ruining yes i agree
they're like i want you to burn yeah
like well you don't know about that it's
actually a fair point like there's
actually a lot more at stake even though
you would think would be the opposite
because you're right the surveillance of
it all's like so creepy it's so creepy
and then you get back to your apartment
and i'll wake up in the middle of the
night and immediately look in the corner
of my room really yeah and look for a
camera and i also think it's weird how
like when lindsay brought home that like
random man and like [ __ ] him like we
were literally watching a sex tape like
it was really
invasive i think about the person that
like sits in our garage and edits it and
watches things all night long oh is
there like a studio in the garage yeah
there's someone that like sits and like
watches us at night and like transcribe
like if we have a fight at like midnight
and no no one can play people yeah
there's no camera people there's no
producer so there's someone being like
okay she fought about this with her and
she said this this and this then lindsay
brought someone home and it's like yeah
so i'm always like i always want to meet
that i meet that person every summer
unique job
oh that's so interesting
and then my last question is always
confusion and i spoke to you about this
privately on instagram is the the way
that you guys pack up every weekend like
i just don't understand if you're
spending the whole summer they're like
why are you guys having big ass away
suitcases that you pull out of your car
up the steps every [ __ ] weekend like
just leave it there some people do it
differently
so like amanda and kyle pack all for
their whole summer and then they leave
everything there
i pack weekend because what if something
happens during the week and you're like
i don't have that pair of shorts and i
really need them so it gives me anxiety
to leave things i get that for me i just
feel like you're the type of girl with
more than one pair of shorts
like i literally have one pair of shorts
but i feel like you have many i do leave
all my like hair and makeup stuff there
like i have a separate set that i'll
leave there but when it comes to clothes
and shoes i need everything accessible
whenever i need it or i'll have a panic
attack got it okay i just feel like you
would be a girl with so many shoes and
accessories like you could just leave
them anywhere you wanted yeah but i'm so
psycho that like i'll go through a phase
where i can only wear that pair yeah of
course of course of course and have you
been to delaware yet i have a few times
okay well paige is here and i'll do
everything in my power like to stop
talking about her and craig but
absolutely no promises are being made
and you're going to join me we're going
to discuss the best five it's also
wednesday which means paige is joining
me for some dear toasters i feel like
you probably are really good at giving
relationship advice like to other people
i pretend that i am yeah by the way like
people are always asking for advice like
[ __ ] i've literally been on one date in
my life and we got married like i'm
either the best dater on the world or
the worst because i've literally only
been on one so we're gonna do our best
to help you guys to whatever it is
you're going through and that's your
toast at the end of the show but before
that paige is joining me to deliver the
fast five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
third love we were talking about them
yesterday um they are the number one bra
for a reason they offer unparalleled
comfort thanks to every unique detail in
their fit style function and design
they're loved and worn by millions of
women
they don't punch or dig into you you
won't want to take it off from the
moment you walk in the door i've always
said that the beauty of third love is
like learning what bra size you actually
are and i didn't know my true bra size
because
no one ever told me until i took their
quiz at third love and now it's truly my
my bra size they do comfort so you can
do you their bras are made by women for
women to fit look and feel great their
bras underwear activewear and feel good
in it all day wear are designed to hug
better hold stronger and support longer
so your bra size can change over six
times in your lifetime so third love
makes it easy to find a bra that
actually fits with their fitting room
quiz the fitting room quiz is like a
personal shopper but better it focuses
on size breast shape current fit issues
and your personal style to find bras
that are perfect for you you'll love
your fit guaranteed if not exchanges and
returns are free for 60 days third
love's team of expert fit stylists are
available to answer all of your
questions feeling is believing give your
boobs the 24 7 comfort and support they
deserve upgrade your bra today and get
20 off your first order at thirdlove.com
toast that's 20 off at thirdlove.com
toast today's episode is also brought to
you by best fiends once you download
best fiends you can play anywhere even
without an internet connection which is
why i love it because i played on the
plane it's a great option for when
you're stuck without wi-fi you can
collect tons of fiends that get powered
up as you play more levels every win
brings new challenges thousands of
puzzles to play and they have new
in-game events that are added all the
time
so with thousands of levels i'm on level
237 there's always more to play so go
ahead and let enough is never enough be
your mantra if you're just looking for
something mindless and really fun um if
you travel a lot or if you're ever
without wi-fi best fiends it's a great
option because you don't need wi-fi to
play download best fiends for free from
the app store or google play plus earn
even more with five dollars worth of
in-game rewards when you reach level
five that's fiends without the r
best beans okay paige wow that was
really good i talked six thousand miles
a minute okay so our first two stories
it's little kardashian news because
kim's interview on gma that's like
making a lot of waves because she was
talking about get your [ __ ] ass up
from work um
we got another sneak peek last night and
she's talking about pete and so is chris
chris is like pete is such a good guy
and then kim kardashian like robin
roberts is doing the lord's work just
asking the questions and she basically
said
i mean i'm a relationship kind of girl
for sure so i wouldn't be with someone
if i didn't plan on spending a lot of
time with them obviously i want to take
my time but i'm very happy and very
content and it's such a good feeling
just to be at peace so like i want to
cry
and i'm so happy
obsessed isn't it weird like
the way i used to think about them like
when we first saw that picture of them
on the roller coaster i was like perfect
yeah rebound everything she needs love
it and now i'm like pete is a dad like
this is everything like he's a stepdad
no he's literally a stepdad and i love
it i love it too i feel like pete i
don't know why i have this feeling that
like pete's our friend from new york
yeah yeah yeah and he's like made it big
and we're so happy for him like we're so
excited to watch his journey 100
i feel like his mom is like freaking out
somewhere and she like wants to get
lunch with us and tell us about it
literally the best part of this whole
thing is his mom because you know she's
like so happy she probably watches
kardashians she's just like a regular
woman from staten island she probably
like loves the show and like for her
this is the best thing that could ever
happen and pete just brought kim to meet
his grandparents in staten island so
it's just like it's too much it's too
much and i think tomorrow or someday
soon is the red carpet premiere for
keeping up with the kardashians new hulu
show and i feel like that will be like
their first red carpet appearance
because it's a great promo for the show
and they're just like in this place like
he i don't even know how when he's in
new york he's supposed to be in new york
every saturday right he's definitely not
he's definitely not he's never on snl
anymore but i feel like doesn't matter
because what pete is doing like pr wise
for snl is just unmatched he
i also heard this rumor i don't know if
it's true that he manifests he's like a
big manifesto oh i wouldn't see that for
him and i don't want to give like wework
vibes of like
you know like changing your
consciousness or whatever but i feel
like he is like very goal-oriented like
who gets on snl at that age anyway i
know no you're right like he's just like
ahead of his time in a while he really
is yeah i feel like he's gonna write a
really good book one day i mean
i honestly never thought like he could
outdo his relationship with ariana
grande because it was psychotic yeah it
was so much so fast engaged tattoos the
dad's you know fdny number on her foot
like it was so much and now i'm like
ariana who
i don't know her i don't even remember
that they got engaged and i love that
like ariana is like clearly very on
board for this because she's really
happy she's married now and she keeps
sending kim all of her rem beauty like
there there's no bad blood no we love we
love women supporting women we love we
love sending our makeup lines to each
other i know we need a makeup line so i
can send it to you and craig
craig woods
i heard that craig like i i heard that i
really tricked craig on april fools
wait did you yes oh cause you said you
were doing which i'm not
um and i heard that craig was like
bereft he was speechless and he was like
i could never go on her show again wait
who did he say that to he and um austin
did a live show at town hall oh yeah
yeah and apparently i was a segment and
someone sent me a bunch of people
actually sent me a video and they were
like craig was freaking out because he
like thought it was real oh my god he's
so naive he's so sweet and you know i
love when he doesn't get pop cultures i
know he's like and honestly i didn't
even think about like the the effect
jumo has had on his life and also on the
season of summer house it's so crazy
he's terrified of dumont
he he texted me like a month ago and he
was like did you know that brad and
angelina broke up and i was like wow oh
my god you're so like 10 years
well just back to pete and kim like i am
really over the moon overjoyed and
i cannot wait to hear this gma special
but there's also a little bit more news
because people are quaking um kim
kardashian has introduced pete to north
and i feel like of all the people in
kim's life like north is probably the
toughest yeah absolutely and if you see
this picture it's paparazzi picture of
them driving around in a golf cart north
on pete's lap she's in heaven she's
obviously like in love with pete and
it's like you thought she was gonna be
tough like with with north for she's
sour yeah then she's sweet i feel like
kim you can say whatever you want about
kim but i in my bones feel like she's a
really good mom of course like i feel
like she's not introducing pete to north
if she is serious isn't serious and had
even like a small gut feeling that like
this wasn't going to be end game i feel
like she's like you're not meeting my
children yeah no kim is everything she's
an entrepreneur she's a model she's
really a sex symbol she's everything but
first and foremost she's a mom and she's
like a die hard like protective mom i
agree i don't think she's just bringing
people into the house to meet the kids
especially north and so the fact that
north loves pete like i want to see
north like boss pete around in the new
season well like i'm really confused
about what we're going to get from kim
and pete on the season because a couple
weeks ago she said like he hasn't been
on the show yet
but like they're literally together
every day so he's like living in her
house and there was a preview that like
chris calls him out for like texting him
yeah like i'm just like i need it no and
then they were in new york i remember
they went to zero bond like they they've
been together so much and all while
she's filming so he's off camera
i don't know but i do love like when
they are together any paparazzi picture
she's like laughing her ass off totally
and kanye was like wear this ski mask
were you silent or were you silenced
right a hundred percent like the
dichotomy of like the two relationships
is like just this is exactly what she
needs i feel like there's a college kid
somewhere like writing a thesis on it
there's something there's something
there like 100 yeah and i'm just so
happy for kim like she's really like a
good time gal and i feel like she's
right she's laughing she's having fun
she's on vacation she's at her kids
soccer games like yep ideal yeah
couldn't be happier for her me either
and i will continue to talk about them
until the day i die so if anyone has
anything they want to say about that
[ __ ] off
um next time we grew up with the
kardashians i don't even need to begin
to justify my obsession like all the
sisters all the sisters obsessed
obsessed like i
i i would literally take a bullet like i
would maybe take a bullet i would cry if
i'm at them okay have you met any of
them no
i'd met kim and how was she like i was
being unwell so like it was it was my
fault like that the meeting didn't go
well and it was just like really rushed
like and then i met chloe and she is
she's the one everything yeah she's the
one like we were at a wedding together
and like all the kardashians were there
yeah and they all were like polite but
they didn't like stay the whole time
chloe was the last one on the dance
floor like drunk with all the games like
she was being iconic i was like that's
my [ __ ] like yeah she was just
everything you wanted her to be in more
yeah and then like courtney and travis
were like licking tongues in the corner
like it was it was unique
um so they're having a great week but
someone who's not having a great week is
erica jane and i feel like she thought
she like might have been out of it but
she's back in it she's been named in a
50 million racketeering lawsuit
she's been labeled as the front woman in
the ex tom gerardi's alleged law alleged
fraud scheme in a 50 million
racketeering lawsuit so erica has been
named in a new case from edelson pc
which is accusing her of using her
public platform to prolong girardi's
firm's alleged scheme all right that's a
stretch okay that's a lot that was a lot
for my brain yeah no and also i don't
really get it this is what they're
saying the victims of tom's fraud have
had to sit back and watch erica spend
obscene amounts of money as they
as they had nothing this is a giant step
forward in obtaining real accountability
for what the largest criminal
racketeering enterprise
in the history of plaintiff's law it's
time for her to stop the lies and start
taking some accountability so they're
basically saying
that
i don't know what they're saying that
she prolonged it because she was on
housewives right i don't really
understand because she was trying to
like spend all the money and show
everyone that she was so cool wouldn't
that have made it go faster because they
ran out of money because she was
spending it so much right i just i do
feel like this is a stretch and honestly
now watching do you watch salt lake city
housewives of course so now watching
like
the gen shop at all i'm like justice for
erica jane like they [ __ ] dragged her
and you know what it was her [ __ ]
husband it wasn't even her jen shaw
didn't get asked one [ __ ]
question and it's her it's not even her
husband yeah her i just think it's so
wild that we live in a world where like
there's housewives that are like going
to jail yeah we're on our third like we
thought the teresa thing was insane it
was but like jen shop like most likely
will go to be going to prison for like
more than 20 years no that's terrifying
and she like sat there at reunion day
and was just like why can't i wear my
gloves they make my outfit and i was
like delusion wait but what if you go to
jail well i know and you know that every
single person that was like put on trial
with her has taken a plea deal except
for her i believe it's 30 people have
taken a plea deal and she's still going
to work she thinks she's like the
anxiety i would have jail is personally
my worst nightmare me too we need
someone at summerhouse to like get into
a financial crime
who do you think it would be
who would go to jail for tax evasion
probably austin even though he's not
like a cat
or like yeah no austin for sure i feel
like andrea could go for tax evasion
because he was like i didn't know
yeah and they're just like it's fine
and he's like so handsome and cute and
sweet he would get there and the judge
would be like it's fine sweetie just be
like you can't go to jail you're right
look at it imagine andrea in jail like
no oh the poor thing oh
um so i really feel like i've personally
had enough of the erica jane like i feel
like she's you know
made it clear that she was not
responsible i do believe her now i
didn't believe her in the beginning i
believe her now and this honestly seems
like a stretch and a half
erica jane i will say this when she
first started on beverly hill first of
all what's your favorite franchise i
mean it depends on the season because a
lot of them are in like lowe's right now
yeah but it's probably beverly hills and
potomac
wow okay well i'm really interested that
you threw in potomac in there potomac is
the most underrated franchise on the
people sleep on it it's so [ __ ] good
and mostly because like the bullet i
would take for karen huger is huge
their last season was incredible amazing
the season before that with the monique
and the candice you know i'd actually
love to get your take on this because as
someone who sat in on reunions like yeah
andy's job is really to be like
completely
what's the word i'm looking for um
indifferent like really a middleman but
he
has i mean he's a human he's a human
he's like favorite certain people and
like at the reunion with the candace and
the monique of it all like he was so
team candice when like yeah candace like
was so wrong so it really pissed me off
because i felt like we never got justice
like the monique fans because it wasn't
a fairy union i was team monique yeah of
course like we're normal
but i'm curious like if you've
experienced like the wrath of andy when
he like wasn't on your side and if you
think he has favorites in your show okay
when the first time i ever went on watch
what happens i was just a bartender with
hannah i don't andy didn't know me from
like literally this box of spreads he
was like thanks for coming not sure who
you are and right but i was so i loved
it yeah i was like so much like and then
i went on again and or no i went to the
clubhouse because craig was on and all
of a sudden andy was like hi paige so i
attribute anything nice that andy says
about me is because he loves he loves
craig he loves he loves the boys of
southern charms so much like chef you're
100 right yeah um and do you feel like
he takes favorites on anyone in
summerhouse like do you think he is
loyal to like kyle and carl i actually
feel with our
cast he's very indifferent because like
he doesn't care yeah i actually do even
think he watches no he's like so what
did you do you had a contract that's
weird tell me about it yeah but when he
was when he was doing what was live for
sierra he like i forget what exactly it
was but he said something that made it
clear like he didn't see the most recent
episode because it was like no that's
actually the opposite of what happened
like so i completely agree i don't think
summerhall i actually do think
summerhouse is climbing andy's list of
priorities i think summerhouse is the
new vanderpump rules wow and i think
like in a few years like we will all
look back on this time in summerhouse
and be like oh my god like the way we
look back on like a chunky cable knit
sweater the jacks era yeah i think
that's what we're gonna feel like about
summer house i agree and there's a huge
gap because like vanderpump rules is the
workshop on television now and nobody
even knows if it's coming back right i
feel like it's going if it does they
have to do like a whole they need a
rebrand
i agree and i think that's what they
tried to do last season but they like
half-assed it they were like we'll keep
so many of the old people while also
rebranding
honestly it's just not believable
anymore that any of these people work at
a restaurant
none of them weren't there not a single
one
it's silly to me um but erica jane yeah
so i would say uh what is your favorite
franchise so i am between beverly hills
and new jersey
jersey i didn't watch last night but
jerseys yes so good i just feel if
you're looking at the longevity of each
franchise jersey has performed pretty
much every year yeah there were those
like dark years with amber and those
twins when theresa was in jail oh i
forgot about it i could never forget
about the twins because they were like
so desperate and then amber and her
crazy ass [ __ ] husband
um but theresa was in jail so like it
was a tough time for everyone you know
which is so crazy no crazy the fact that
like the first episode of like a recent
season of jersey is teresa coming home
from jail is psychotic i got it did you
also see she's like being outspoken
saying she doesn't know if she's going
to film her wedding
yes
you're a bravo liberty and you are
dating a bravo liberty like would you
have a filmed wedding okay this is like
a very interesting conversation in my
home because craig and i
talk about it all the time because there
are certain things that people like
expect you to do right it's like well
we've seen your whole relationship how
dare you feel
privacy yeah like do this
but when craig like initially asked me
to be his girlfriend we were off camera
and i
when he did that i always thought like
wow i'm so happy you did this off camera
because i'm a girl yeah and there would
have been a thought in my mind that was
like did he just do it to have a moment
and then the first time he told me he
loved me
was off camera but like southern charm
was filming but we were like
like those moments should be private
right so like having these little
moments where it's just me and him i
really cherish just because there's so
many times where people are like
oh yeah you're laying in bed and like
what like what's going on
and even though you are a reality star
like you are entitled to a good amount
of privacy and like i don't subscribe to
that notion that just because you're on
a reality show like but theresa is
different
needs to show her wedding um nobody
cares about my potential wedding oh we
care a lot but i completely agree teresa
is different for a multitude of reasons
and she doesn't get privacy yeah
sorry
we watched you go to jail we no we can
watch you walk down the aisle i've seen
literally every moment like it's just
it's not happening
she's also been on for like 20 years no
and the show like literally saved her
life in so many ways like there's no way
like right she has to do it
um
okay well we've got more news about
other people being billionaires who are
not me which is very upsetting um and
it's brought to you by thuma practice is
an intentional lessons more design
philosophy for the bedroom so with clean
lines subtle curves and lifestyle and
enhancing details thumb approves that
simplicity is the truest form of
sophistication so introducing the bed by
thuma their handcrafted eco-friendly
high quality upcycled wood is stunning
you'll find beautiful unique variations
in the natural grain the minimalist
design featuring japanese joinery helps
elevate any space it's super supportive
for your mattress it's breathable and
it's made to naturally minimize noise
and create space so everything from
thuma but especially the bed is just
like it's giving peace it's giving peace
by taylor swift it's so stunning
it's all really really high quality and
it's made for how you live so their bed
is backed by a lifetime warranty it
ships right to your door in three easy
to maneuver boxes and it takes about
five minutes to assemble with no tools
required which is a gift because the
leading cause of divorce in this country
is trying to set up furniture with your
husband um and a five-minute bed is
something i can really get on board with
along with the bed they offer other
bedroom essentials to elevate bedtime
like their nightstand the side table and
the tray are perfect complements to the
bed i have the nightstand the side table
and the tray um they work with one tree
planted so they plant a tree for every
bed and nightstand sold so all of their
essentials are green guard gold
certified so create that feeling of
checking into your favorite boutique
hotel suite but at home with the bed by
thuma now go to thuma dot co slash toast
and use the code toast to receive a 25
credit towards your purchase of the bed
plus free shipping in the continental us
that's t h u m a dot c o slash toast
enter toast at checkout for a 25 credit
thuma dot co slash toast code toast
okay so rihanna jay-z and kanye have
finally made like the coveted uh forbes
billionaires list for the first time
each which i find really shocking that
jay-z wasn't on wait uh yeah i always
thought jay-z was like the richest one
of all of them me too so
rihanna who was officially certified as
a billionaire in august 2020
thanks to her beauty and lingerie empire
landed at this is this is so crazy she
landed at number
1729 on the list so rihanna's the and i
think it's america the like 1700th
richest person which is so crazy because
i mean i've been dating for like 15
years i haven't met one of those people
and that's annoying for me kanye um who
has disputed his overall value with
forbes like they're always fighting
about how much he's actually worth um i
love when celebrities get into fights
with like major brands it's always the
kardashians fighting with forbes about
like what their true value is like
because they said kanye was worth two
billion and he says he was worth seven
and that's like a really big disparity
it's not nothing
he's number one thousand five hundred
and thirteen thanks to obviously yeezy
and gap
and then
oh and rihanna is the first billionaire
from barbados which is really cool
um and i'm curious uh if you had a
billion dollars yeah what would you do
this is my favorite game to play like if
you won the lottery and you got one
billion with a b
how would you spend it and if you if you
want some inspiration this is what i say
i would always do
so unfortunately we live in a greedy
[ __ ] country so i'd have to
give 500 million to taxes it's about 50
so i have 500 million
automatically i'm putting 250 million
dollars in like a really high yielding
um
some like
investing yeah so that i never really
have to work again but my money will
earn money for me right and then the
other 250 million i would say about 50
of that is going to go to different
homes like i'm going to buy like a beach
house right a mountain house a penthouse
so i think 50 million is enough for like
three homes yeah cars etc maybe a boat
the other 200 i have left like i will be
giving to friends and family not all of
it maybe
maybe 5 million i'll be giving no okay
i'll give another 50 to like friends
family
another you know 25 to charity
well that's [ __ ] up okay maybe like
another 50 to charity um and then just
like spend the rest like just like
bathing in the money being really happy
about the money i'm spending on whatever
i want like going like on vacations
getting like the best table at every
club in the city like everyone knows
normal things yeah
i this is like the best miss usa
question i would love to see how those
[ __ ] answer all right if somebody
forgets charity like you're done
you're done
um okay first thing i would do is call
my dad because i would just be like what
do i do happening here um and then he
would be like you probably have to give
it all to me and i'll figure it out
um no i think i would like call my
family and be like how much do you guys
need let's take that right off the top
so smart then i'm calling like a really
good financial planner and being like
please don't steal all my money that's
the tough part
so i feel like you have to have two yeah
because like so one can check in on the
other one unless they both conspire
against you no which is by that you
should have two but they shouldn't be in
communication with each other because in
case one of them turns out to be corrupt
at least you still have some money left
okay so we're getting two they're
opposite sides of the planet yeah they
don't know each other one in israel and
one in america
so far once and so they'll never meet
um and then yeah i'm doing homes i want
like a huge yacht
like i want like a yacht that people are
like
thought yeah like anna delby tries to
get on
exactly and then i need to fly private
for the rest of my life of course so do
you think if you had let's say 500
million dollars you would buy a plane or
just be like a charter girly
oh my god because it's really expensive
to have a plate i would think i would
call net jets and be like let's figure
something out and like have everything
pink and velvet inside right i don't
really understand the need unless you
have like
bezos money right you really don't need
your own plane it's so expensive to like
you know the staff and the hanger when
like whenever you want to go somewhere
you just drop 250 grand for like a
big-ass plane and they're all really
nice that's the way to go i think so too
like kylie and kim like both just got
their own planes but and they're both
like billionaires with a baby don't you
get annoyed that like you would be such
a good rich person
no you you want to hear like how
delusional i am
i like will lose sleep over the fact
that like the kardashians don't have me
in their life as a friend because like i
really i know what they need in a friend
for like obviously someone funny like
i'm i bring so much to the table right
but i'm also like extremely loyal and
like i know how important family is and
like i just know i'm the perfect person
to be their friend right and it keeps me
up at night and i feel sad for them that
they'll never have me
as that and like that's how unwell i am
i i actually agree with that yeah and
i'm just like you don't even know what
you're missing out on because i feel
like they only have chloe who's funny so
like their base is just like yeah that's
funny they need more they need more
comedy friends no i'm like they don't
even know like the value i would bring
to their life
i gotta and and it keeps me up at night
obviously because i'm sad on what i'm
missing out on but i'm actually like i
feel sorry for them like me too like
they're never gonna know what it's like
to have someone as like [ __ ] amazing
right and you know what it's their loss
it's they're very jealous they're just
jealous i completely agree and you know
chloe like was the funny one but i feel
like she's kind of been like broken down
by by everyone battered and beaten yeah
and it's like i don't even think she's
funny and i like i don't know her
personally like i just feel like the
world has been so mean to her for so
long
i don't get either like people used to
be so mean to her about the way she
looked and then like she got so s so
thin and so like self-conscious and now
people are like you're too skinny you
edit your photos too much and it's like
yeah leave this [ __ ] [ __ ]
alone and the whole tristan thing i'm
like oh my god you guys haven't dated
like the worst man in america right
right like you haven't called your ex i
have four on speed diamonds literally
the hypocrisy like yeah why the
kardashians have to be perfect is beyond
me yeah
all right next story is like very
nuanced and very irrelevant but like i
happen to care a lot
katie holmes is showing off her edgy
style as she got a nose ring i love nose
rings okay i actually it made me think
the first thing i thought of when i saw
the snowstorm and made me think of
amanda petula yeah who like there could
be a world war and she won't take her
nose right now like she is obsessed and
i wanted to ask you if she wore her nose
ring to her wedding yes she did you're
kidding yep she wore her nose ring to
her wedding but she's the kind of person
that like i never notice it in pictures
by the way i agree like i didn't really
notice she had a nose ring and then i
think i maybe noticed a couple weeks and
i'm like oh yeah she's always had it
like it's not
so it's so in your face yeah it's like
there are certain girls that like
like you could see a girl walking down
the street and she's fully sleeve tatted
and you're like she looks so cool yeah
if i did that they'd be like what's
going on right lock her up and nose
rings i feel like are the same like with
amanda i'm like you're so artsy and you
like love graphic design yeah and like
you're cool and she can do it yeah no i
agree and i didn't really see this for
katie holmes but katie holmes has been
through so much like the tom cruise of
it all the scientology of it all like if
home girl wants to get a nose ring like
do it she had a face tattoo just to
reclaim her independence yeah
i'm so
fascinated by scientology doesn't kind
of look like katie holmes anyone ever
tell you that no but thank you like
young katie holmes thank you it's
totally a compliment remember when she
dated the guy from the restaurant yes of
course i mean that was a that was a time
period that i really lived for you're
right like katie holmes has
really existed in so many different
lifetimes like the dawson's creek of it
all yep the tom cruise of it all i feel
like surrey then the surrey cruise of it
all is going to like date mason disick
okay suri in if the way i see siri
growing up is like being like a full
socialite and like giving taylor momsen
she she is blair waldorf yes i think i
think that like we aren't ready as a
society for the looks that surrey's
gonna serve
absolutely and her name is so unique do
you remember when like the country was
quaked down by the name surrey like yeah
people couldn't believe it i was like
11. i was like sorry sir is going to the
met gala oh a hundred percent even
though i do think like her mom is really
scarred by fame yeah and i think siri
maybe saw that firsthand and like will
actually not be like a famous girly
interesting yeah that's what she might
be one of those like but that's gonna
make her even cooler right like she
doesn't even know she's hiding from it
but it's making her so much bigger
like i'm already obsessed with her like
i look to see what she wears yeah of
course does she have an instagram i
don't know but i saw them at pastice one
time and i
there are certain people that you'll see
in new york city where i get
legitimately so star struck katie holmes
was one of us of course she's an
institution yeah and i
i
spend more time than i care to admit
thinking about the tom cruise of it all
yeah because he's such a [ __ ] weirdo
and i really think about what he did to
nicole kidman yeah which is very similar
that what he did to katie holmes in that
you know nicole kidman was like the
scientology [ __ ] is not for me yeah
i'm so i'm gonna go
and then he like made all of their kids
like shun her and a lot of
some of her kids talk to her some of
them don't all because of scientology
and it's so [ __ ] whack and i just
like
i have always wanted to walk into the
scientology building and do not and get
a pamphlet just to see what they say
like i watch
like do not go i watch so many
documentaries i find it so clear
is a national hero yeah
so i just did a show in clearwater
florida which is like
by tampa but it's like this kind of
small beach town and it's the
headquarters of scientology so we were
at the capitol theater which is
literally around the block from like the
oh the sea org yes yes the big property
when i tell you that the town is barren
like the every shop is closed it's so
it's a war zone it's the scariest way
it's like this dead ass town and then
the beach is a couple blocks over it's
like a couple blocks over it's like pop
it it's like st petersburg area okay but
that town that's right by it's
empty it literally looks like a movie
set like how there's no windows and do
they all like live there so yeah and so
if you work for the sea org you dress
basically like a flight attendant okay
and so when we were like walking into
the venue like the only people on the
street they were dressed like literally
like scientology airlines like it was
crazy that's terrifying it was so scary
i was like we drove out that night i'm
like we are getting the [ __ ] out of here
like it's creepy i went to see the book
of mormon last night so good well i
slept through the first half what it's
so good i know craig was so mad at me do
craig stay up he loves musicals i think
that falling asleep not to put you on
blast in a broadway show is
peak disrespect like did you have good
seats like did you see your great seats
and i've never stayed awake through any
broadway show that's psychotic like
they're so loud and bright like i have
slept through um
what's the one with the wizard of oz
wicked wickets that's disgraceful
hamilton fell asleep for like 15 minutes
never saw hamilton so i i can't speak to
it aladdin fell asleep yeah ben saw he
said it wasn't good um and book of
mormon fell asleep but you're missing
out book of mormon is so funny it is
very funny like i it's the only show
i've gone to and i physically have
laughed out loud okay like the fact that
like you and craig are going to broadway
shows like i'm gonna die like loves
going to them
yeah
craig is like he gets like so just a
musical theater girly he loves going and
like getting the wine at like the bar
and getting all the snacks
he loves the whole you get dressed up
um he wore a blazer and he literally got
home
no one dresses up to like go they don't
you go to the theater and it's not right
it's not right and then we started
talking in british accents and i was
like no one has any cous oh my god i'm
so
speechless yeah from that we should do a
double date
do not tease me because like we will be
there i'll be there 15 minutes we went
to quality bistro before so good so good
there's a lot of good restaurants in
like the theater district yeah
just watch that then you make it like a
night did you take like a pedicab home
no we didn't [ __ ] that would have been
cute yeah maybe if you had your own tv
show you guys they would have made you
maybe if we filmed our wedding they
would have left maybe
um okay final story is a little tech
news because we're just like such a
well-rounded show we talk about all the
things twitter is working on an edit
button so as any true blue twitter user
knows the divide over the social network
adding an edit button is the deepest
ideological ravine of our time i'm at
techcrunch.com relax so you're thinking
about adding an edit button which is
like crazy definitely something i could
have used in high school when i was
tweeting offensive things about
literally everyone um and i just feel
like it's a little late
okay wait but also did you hear that
elon musk basically like bought twitter
we reported on that yesterday basically
he became because it's a publicly traded
company he became the biggest
shareholder he just bought billions of
dollars of shares and now he owns nine
percent of the company and then twitter
was like open to working with him so
they gave him a board seat
so does that mean he like walks in and
he's like i want this this and this
change and like is he behind the edit
button so i don't know if he's behind it
but i do imagine having a board seat
comes a lot of power so if you wanted
something done like having a board seat
would be a great place to start so you
can go back to previous tweets click
edit and be like no i actually love
jay-z right and like
i guess it probably would say edited
like on instagram if you edit the
caption it does say edited
um it does yeah really small wait i
don't love that no i know i've also
never known because i always have a typo
so it's my every single one of my
captions are edited well one of my
girlfriends will always text me and be
like you should have made the caption
this and i'm like [ __ ] that literally
just happened to me 100 i'm like you're
so right that's so much fun you know
also sometimes like if you post
something with like a mediocre caption
and like oh like podcast fans are like
really funny and smart yeah so they're
always like dropping hilarious comments
and i'm like literally [ __ ] i'm taking
that from myself
so i just for me and this is what we
were talking about yesterday like
twitter as a social media platform is so
irrelevant yeah um i don't really feel
like any update they make is gonna
change the landscape of social media
moving forward
i just like don't care about twitter do
you tweet like
you don't live tweet your show or
anything no rebel liberties love to do
that especially the housewives i feel
like i would only ever go on twitter to
like
maybe i'll follow some comedians that
tweet something funny or like maybe look
up a pop culture story but like i don't
care what like
diplomats are tweeting no you know like
i don't care it's just not my personal
niche and i find like the the only time
i really use twitter is like when
there's breaking news like yesterday
there was like a joe rogan death hoax
like they're always doing that on
twitter like and that's why when like
then people die like i remember when
there were reports that kobe did i'm
like there's no way there's always these
hoaxes on twitter so it's like you don't
believe it i feel like it's like the
girls that kept diaries in middle school
and i was just never a diary girl no and
i'm not really like
like
like like well read like you know what i
mean
i don't really know how to like the fact
that i put a book together is beyond
mine like because like i can't even put
together like a tweet that like makes
sense i
literally read half a book this year and
it was great
oh that's so sweet we actually have it
over here i've been meaning to read it
craig came out with a book craig came
out with a book and there's literally
two chapters about like him and his
ex-girlfriend i was like i feel like is
it rude if i don't read it i think about
naomi yes and i felt like i was actually
reading his diary i was like i feel like
i shouldn't read this you should like
tell me if you want to tell me what is
your relationship with with naomi like
she is first of all she's stunning
stunning obsessed like in person like
obviously she's studying on instagram
but like in person she's even prettier
um she's very nice very lovely like you
know he she is his ex-girlfriend so it's
not like best friends i'm not gonna be
like oh my god
[Laughter]
you know like i'm gonna do that but like
i can be in a room with her and it's
like totally normal and like fine but
well actually i was reading some stuff
about craig's book where he was talking
about that um you know at the beginning
of the show on
southern charm yeah he was having like
an adderall problem which that was
really interesting and i think it
happens to a lot of reality stars
absolutely and he was well i was like
looking at pictures from when he was
first on i was like he's so skinny yeah
and i was like and i feel like as girls
and like going to college we know
exactly what that is right like you're
on a roll no one told you come on
oh also one more question i logistically
had to ask you before we keep going
it appears as though when you guys wake
up in the morning after a party everyone
cleans except for you yeah and i just
want to know like is that a bad edit or
are you just not cleaning
so like both but also people are so mad
about it i got that question like a
thousand times and i will take if that
is the one thing that like they're
taking bad from me from the show it's
like she's lazy i'm like totally fine
yeah
um
i don't help clean or set up as much as
everyone else but like i do do it but
some people are like
so crazy does it bother the other
housemates no they don't give a [ __ ]
yeah like i feel like a lot of tv shows
like what specifically when i think back
on jersey shore so many of the fights
were like we did dinner you guys have to
do the dishes there's always like
housework which is coming we have a
cleaning person so that was the other
question it's like do you guys because
it gets really clean after like yeah
when you leave on sunday someone comes
in during the week and they clean it and
they clean it and like do you guys think
that when bravo puts a deposit down for
the house that they get it back
absolutely not no because when amanda
was talking about like the ripped um i
don't think
yeah no but like we yeah i don't know
any of like those logistical things but
just from like attending a frat party a
few times in my life i don't think we
get i don't think so either a deposit
back me neither um okay well those were
the fast five congratulations on making
it through your first fast five thank
you thank you so much for doing that
with me and i'm gonna hold you ransom
for 20 more minutes because today is
wednesday
that's dear toasters so if you ever want
to write in it's dear toasters at
gmail.com we'll always keep it anonymous
for you if you're having any issues at
work at home with your boyfriend
whatever it is you know your boss is
hoarding water bottles in the basement i
don't know
[ __ ] happens write in test your toasters
at gmail.com and we'll do our best to
guide you through we're just two girls
trying to do our best so dear toasters
is brought to you by catalina crunch if
you're trying to eat better catalina
crunch cereal has the crunch you crave
without any of the empty carbs it's
absolutely delicious most zero sugar
food doesn't taste delicious but can
only eat a crunch really nailed it
there's zero sugar low carb and keto
friendly plus it packs a whopping 11
grams of plant-based protein and nine
grams of fiber per serving taste fire
taste for yourself why over ten thousand
customers rate catalina crunch five
stars they've got eight crave worthy
flavors to choose from like nostalgia
inducing cinnamon toast dark chocolate
creamy chocolate peanut butter and if
you're not sure which flavor to try
first then try the variety pack
that's what they're there for they're
gluten free grain free non-gmo only real
clean ingredients nothing artificial so
if you're a mindless snacker like me and
you just like watch a lot of tv and just
want to shove food down your mouth um
catalina crunch is a great option
because it's way healthy and super
delicious see why catalina crunch cereal
is the fastest growing cereal brand in
america go to catalina
catalinacrunch.comtoast for fifteen
percent off your first order plus free
shipping that's catalinacrunch.com toast
again if you're not sure which flavor to
start with try the red variety pack and
check out their delicious cookies and
snack mixes while you're at it again
that's
catalinacrunch.com toast for 15 off your
first order plus free shipping it's a
[ __ ] catalina wine mixer okay
first up someone's writing in paige and
claudia bless you both for helping me
when this scenario came up i knew i
needed to write in immediately the drama
i love you are like a danielle steel
novel
we are very happy oh no sorry i skipped
line i'm an east coast girly but
relocated to the west coast and i met my
now husband here we are very happy in
california but it's expensive my parents
my husband's parents have a few rental
homes in san diego san diego and they
offered to sell us one of them under
market value the house they want to sell
us is beautiful modern and it has a view
of the water but it's next door to them
my husband is considering it and i'm
naturally most concerned about having
any boundaries with living so close to
them my husband's dad also travels quite
a bit for work and i notice his mom
reaches out a lot when his dad is gone
and he wants to keep wants us to keep
her company so i can imagine what she
would expect with us next door part of
me feels like this could be a recipe for
disaster but i'm curious if you think
differently thank you so much in advance
well my first thought is you said they
have a lot of rental homes so are any of
the other ones available that aren't
next door to them right because that
could be
the problem solver
okay
i might have an unpopular opinion i
would love it
really i would love it because once they
start having kids yes get right on over
to your grandma that's number one like
for sure get out of my house yeah go go
so i love that also
i
love my mom so much so like if she was
next door
okay but what if it was craig's mom like
you love her even more yeah i actually
agree i guess it depends on what the
relationship is with your in-laws like
if you [ __ ] hate them like this is
obviously not
good but if you i agree first of all
like if you have kids and your in-laws
live next door like right goodbye
i have always said to craig i am sending
my kids to delaware for the first five
years of their life yes like learn how
to be nice normal people and then we'll
take them back 100
i've been thinking about that a lot
lately because you know jackie just had
a baby and like i love my in-laws and
i'm like actually feeling so grateful
for them because i'm like you know when
i have a baby like
here
you go help when i go on tour like i
drop my dog off and they love thea and
they're super like they're excited they
felt like a burden for them even though
i feel like i'm burdening them so like
this could be great when i have a kid
like goodbye like i also i feel like
okay yes if the mother's husband is like
going away yeah you're gonna she's gonna
come over for dinner and stuff but like
she's not gonna like walk into the
bedroom when you guys are like having
sex yeah you really paint a good picture
of what this woman's like because she
she might be like that so like that's
the case hard no but i don't know i'm a
sucker for a bargain on a home yeah and
you know
in every home buying experience there's
a give-and-take you know right and
you're getting an undervalued under
market value house and so what you gotta
dinner with your in-laws once a month
yeah it's not a big deal and you have a
babysitter next door i know free daycare
is not something you should take lightly
maybe she's not even thinking about
having kids yet you know i don't know
that's true that's true i think uh i
think it's fine i think it's fine also
and like if it's really not fine you
make something up and you move yeah 100
we have a rat problem like yeah so then
i guess once you live there like will
they take offense when you do end up
moving like if you move then it's like
you have to explain to them you know
yeah i mean there is a potential huge
family fight
that we're like we'll put a camera crew
in there
so you can watch it no i know but it
does have water views so hello in san
diego like that's hard to find yeah i
think you should just take the house
like also they should really just give
it to you but it's fine yeah um all
right hello girlies i'm in a bit of a
pickle
our best friend just got engaged to our
other best friend his name is maverick
maverick threw a surprise engagement
party for her with an open bar we all
traveled across the country
well okay so it's actually
uh a reference to my new york times
bestselling book um when i talked about
the first boyfriend like the first boy i
ever loved like when i was in seventh
grade his name was something but i had
to change a name so um the publisher was
like you need to come up with a name and
i'm like you came up and i got really
flustered it was like last minute i was
like
maverick because the boy's original name
started with an m so i wanted to keep it
similar so i was like map i don't know
where the [ __ ] it came from i'm gonna
love it every time someone writes in
they name their fake boyfriend maverick
it's like so embarrassing
okay so maverick threw a surprise
engagement party um with an open bar we
all traveled across the country bought
flights hotels gas etc the party was
amazing our best friend was so happy
fast forward a week later we received a
group email from maverick asking if we
could contribute money to the food
drinks and cost of the space he rented
for the party keep in mind half the
people in attendance at the party
weren't even on the email chain which
begs the question why are we paying for
other people's food and alcohol as well
you can say we are a bit surprised we
just feel it's a little tacky since we
traveled to the destination and he's
asking for the money for the party that
he planned plus the amount he's asking
is way more than what we would have in
them than what we individually ate slash
drink while in attendance what are your
thoughts on this do you think we should
contribute money should we ignore the
email and pretend we never saw it
do we just continue to contribute the
amount of money that we feel we spent
are we the cheap ones if we don't pay
anything any advice would be greatly
appreciated we promise to follow up with
an update once you've solved this pickle
sincerely two confused toasters who are
potentially the cheap ones
you are not cheap at all literally this
is the most hotspotic thing i've ever
heard in my [ __ ] audacity the
audacity
do not respond to this email no ignore
your life choi someone else's life
choices are not your responsibility like
you show up to a party
as a guest and you spent a lot of money
to be there like [ __ ] off also a
surprise engagement party is no
different than like a surprise birthday
party yeah it could have been her
birthday and he was throwing her a party
would he have asked you for money for
that you know and the thing is like we
are all
just trying to survive and like live
within really live within our means i
didn't know how much she was asking for
i know so if you like overspend it's
really not on your friends right to help
you out of that pickle like that was a
life choice we're adults you're getting
married like these are things you have
to learn financial health yeah
responsibility like that's on you [ __ ]
like sorry no
also i just feel like
that if you couldn't afford it then
don't throw the party right or like make
some cutbacks you know or don't have to
be open bar right if i'm showing up to a
party like i want to drink and so if i
have to pay for one i'll pay for it yeah
because it's always going
something that's wedding related that's
not open bar
okay but i do have to say it's an
engagement party not a wedding so i do
believe a wedding should be open bar and
like for me that's my priority so i
would cut budget on other things like
i'd have no flowers right no flowers
like
no anything no lights just for
the bar because that's my priority right
so for an engagement party i do think
you can get away with the cash bar i do
yeah um but this is so tacky like yeah
so he's worried about being tacky so he
doesn't open bar but then he's not
worried about being tacky and he'll
email all his friends being like hey can
you ban me a hundred dollars like no and
i feel like it was more than a hundred
dollars of course and she said he wrote
like half the party but then it's like
how do you decide which people should
give money and which people shouldn't
also like then when all of those people
get invited to the wedding they're going
to be like [ __ ] this are we going to pay
for it no and like weddings or being a
guest of someone at a wedding is so
expensive if it's a nest destination
wedding you spend so much money on
flights hotels and then the gift if
you're in the bridal party you have the
bridal shower it's like so much money
you spend on other people's wedding yeah
so to ask for even more to contribute to
like the fund for the engagement party
is like really chutzpah like i don't
like it like they're gonna have to go to
her shower they're gonna have to get her
wedding yeah just being a wedding guest
in general is like really pricey yeah
don't invite me don't invite me that's
the thing it's like i
people
don't know the favor they do me when
they don't invite me to their wedding
like hannah's not having a wedding party
and the first thing i said was bless you
god bless you like thank you so much no
and unless i'm like your best friend or
family yeah i usually will reply no to a
wedding because i don't want to take up
space you get charged per person i'm
like yeah i'm not really happy for this
couple so like when the pandemic
happened i got chopped from so many
weddings
god bless
love this is amazing amazing like i just
don't really like weddings unless i'm
like really invested in the couple yeah
then it's like i'm taking up space from
someone else who could have been there
and it's pricey the more people you have
yeah i feel like i'm always doing people
a favor when i say that i'm just sitting
there really judging everything being
like i would never have that you know
everything of course and i'm always
saying like my wedding was better my
feet hurt like the steak is gross like
can we go home now yeah it's always like
how much time has passed that it's a
then an appropriate time to leave
because you can't leave too early right
and like jewish weddings are really long
oh yeah jewish weddings are very well
you have you guys have a very long
ceremony yes well you can get it done
quickly my ceremony was about an hour
yeah um and my favorite part of the
wedding is um
one of my friends mom like took this
great video of like me and ben smashing
the glass and kissing so she sent it to
me like a week after the wedding and i
was like so excited i'm listening
she's filming and finally everyone gets
up and stands once you kiss and one of
ben's friends in the background is like
my god that was so [ __ ] long
that's
amazing it's like the best video it's
true like it was long i love jewish
weddings because when you're doing the
ceremony your family's up there yeah i
love that i think it's their all your
immediate family is like under the hip
hop which is yeah i think that's really
nice yeah actually i love jewish
weddings but they are long like that's
just but they are very fun very fun and
like lots of my most fun weddings have
been jewish weddings yeah no and like
they're they're in my opinion the
perfect balance of like really
meaningful in the beginning and then
yeah
diabolical yeah at the end
okay so i don't remember what advice we
gave you but do not [ __ ] answer that
email no
third and final one
i've been dating my boyfriend for two
and a half years let's call him craig
okay we currently live together
everything has gone so well he's a p
john which stands for precious gem of a
man he treats me like a princess and i
know we will get married one day and we
speak about it constantly his family's
amazing loves me so much i love them
yada yada
i thought my family felt the same way
about my boyfriend but last weekend with
my mom she asked me about my easter
plans and we didn't really do anything
for easter and i agreed to go with my
boyfriend to his grandma's my mom
flipped out on me and said just so i
know
just so i know you'll probably be doing
whatever craig wants for the rest of his
life
and this girl says i'm so taken aback
and confused because i have a great
relationship with my mom her opinion
means so much to me and she accused me
of spending all my time with my
boyfriend and his family and then
falsely accused him of not wanting me to
spend time with my own family she then
specifically brought up a time where i
had gone to my aunt's house with my
entire family everyone was drunk having
a good time it was almost 11 o'clock
we'd been there for hours and i was
borderline blackout pretty much blackout
and i don't remember leaving my
boyfriend made me leave because i was
wasted and now my mom was like looking
back on that
and took it as my boyfriend trying to
control me and made me leave my aunt's
house early even though i don't get to
see them often my mother then said so
when you wonder why we don't care for
craig that's one of the reasons i'm
absolutely devastated about this entire
thing i haven't spoken to my mom since
saturday and it's now tuesday i haven't
spoken to my boyfriend about this i know
he would be heartbroken i just can't
ever imagine my boyfriend's family
speaking about me in this way i have no
clue what to do what do i say to my mom
do i tell my boyfriend any advice on how
to mend the situation would be the
greatest help sincerely a toaster with
mommy issues sounds like your mom's
really toxic honestly wait it sounds
exactly like her mom knows that she's
going to marry this guy and she's kind
of like losing her baby and this is like
her trying to sound like freaking out
about it yeah that's true but like how
do you fix this
this is insane no i literally changed my
name and move yeah no i know it's like
the worst thing ever like family
infighting like you never want to be a
part of that um and it sounds like craig
is a great guy and his name is craig so
i got back out of b i feel like you also
can't tell craig this no no because then
in his mind forever it'll always be like
oh her mom even if things are going well
oh her mom doesn't like actually like me
do not tell him like figure it out on
your own i feel like she has to talk to
her mom and then for like maybe a couple
weeks
do some family things with her family i
know but then it's like you're rewarding
your mom for her toxic behavior that's
true i know and i'm just like so
stubborn like if you're like this your
mom is wrong right you have to remember
this guy for two years and you live with
him like what did she think right now
it's all now suddenly you don't like him
yeah like this is the conversation you
have when you just meet someone
i think she has to have a real
conversation with her mom being and say
like are you being serious when you say
you don't like that this is annoying
because like we're gonna get married so
let's just like iron this out now
communication is key and it's hard to
communicate because like you always want
to be respectful of your elders and you
really do value and respect your mom but
you have to be like you know
right obviously you're pregnant like
controlling me right like me going home
at 11 for my aunt's house because i'm
blacked out isn't me being in a
controlling relationship it's just me
having to go home because yeah you want
me to throw up on my answers actually
him being really nice yeah right like
because nobody wants me to stay here any
longer because it's gonna turn
diabolical so talk to your mom figure it
out do not tell your boyfriend because
like it'll just ruin things yeah men are
so just like dramatic and they're just
so like one track mind like he'll just
remember forever
the one time your mom didn't like you if
you guys were together for 50 years like
there's just yeah there's no reason to
make it bad but thank you for writing in
thank you to everyone who wrote in and
trusting us with your quandaries if you
ever want to write in it's dear toasters
gmail.com and if you want to update us
on something that we helped you with
like let us know you guys leave us
hanging all the time like just write a
[ __ ] email quandary is a great word
it's uh pretty much the word i use every
time for deer toasters and i'm not 100
sure if it's like the right one so i
like breeze right by them like your
quantities and your queries and i'm like
i don't know
i think it's like a science body yeah
it's like so game of thrones
um paige i really can't express my
gratitude enough for you for being here
you are everything of the sort as well
oh my god i feel the same way about you
thank you for even like thinking of me
to have me on honestly you were top of
mind and the toasters would have slipped
my throat if i didn't have you and i'm
so glad we finally got you on you did
amazing sweetie thank you everyone
follow page on instagram for premium
fashion content oh also do you have a
new line coming out with amazon is that
what i saw on your instagram i actually
have one today
and then i have my amazon drop is coming
out so amazon drop is like your own line
of clothing yes oh i can't wait yeah i
have a live today and then my line comes
out in may that is so sick yeah i'm
excited so fashion girly host of the
googly squad podcast available
everywhere
with hannah who was remember you guys
here on friday and you're also going on
tour so just follow page on instagram
for premium content left right and
center thank you so much thank you so
much you guys thank you so much for
listening to the morning toast the
millennial morning show where we deliver
the fast food stories that you need to
know every monday friday on youtube so
if you're watching this on youtube
please feel free to subscribe give this
video a thumbs up we're all available as
a podcast and we're podcasting we found
spotify action stitcher public video why
everybody catch box all the places
wherever listen to the podcast find us
more in chile so everybody beautiful
signings where we are have an amazing
day everyone we'll see you tomorrow
remotely with jackie o finally making
her return bye
how do you do that
you